The answer is 0.99998. There are 2 ways to solve this.
One is to sum these two. Not too hard to do.
The other way to solve it is to use the complementary event property,
which makes the math a little easier in this case.
That property is that we know the sum of all possible events has to be 1.
Instead of computing P valid by adding the probabilities of heads and tails,
we can compute it by subtracking from 1 the probability of events not invalid,
which is the probability of E, which is 0.00002.
That would get us the same answer.
The property that we're using to do this is the complementary even property.
What it states is that for any event A, the probability of that event
and the probability of the complement of that event--
that is of that not happening--is equal to 1.
What not-A here means is that elements in the universe minus the elements in A.
This is set subtraction. We can think of that like this.
This is our universe if we have some event A all outcomes that are not part of a
must be the complement of A.
That's what you get by removing A from the probability set.